what is going on everybody and welcome
to a bit of an R D video with open
assistance pythia 12 b or 12 billion
parameter model this is a model that you
can run completely locally you can
download the weights and use it however
you please it's been trained with open
assistance through our lhf or
reinforcement learning through human
feedback and in my experience it's a
pretty solid model you still might need
if you have a particular task you're
trying to get it to do for you you might
need to do a few shot a few shot
learning in the prompt before you get to
what you're trying to do but overall I'd
say it's quite a solid model and I
definitely recommend checking it out so
anyways with that let's go ahead and
begin working with it so the first thing
I'm going to do is go ahead and touch
and we'll just call this basic
openassistant.pi
and we will open that in lovely vs code
we will also make it nice and big okay
so uh to start what we're going to do is
I'm going to import a transfer actually
what we're going to do is from
Transformers we're going to import auto
two thank you uh at least tokenizer Auto
tokenizer and then Auto uh model for
casual Auto
model 4 casual
language model cool
we don't update in the Centex house uh
anyways then we're going to import torch
yes sir and then we're going to import
OS you don't necessarily have to import
OS for what I'm going to do but
basically because this model it requires
either 24 gigabytes of memory at half
Precision or 48 gigs at full Precision
so 32-bit float
the problem is even if you have a 24
gigabyte graphics card let's say you
still are are not going to be able to
fit it if that's also your main GPU that
powers like your desktop environment
it's not you're not going to have enough
you need truly all every little bit and
then even if you're using it as a
dedicated card uh I have found at half
Precision it still can overflow so keep
that in mind if you intend to use it so
uh first things first we are going to
specify our model name and in our case
uh let me actually pull it up so if we
go to hugging face uh we can just type
uh I guess I'll just do oast
yeah and this is the one that we're
looking for and keep in mind that as
time goes on there might be a more
recent version so this one I started you
know tinkering and playing with this
model when it was the first iteration
and we're already up to the fourth
iteration so it's been out for like a
month or so so anyway
um maybe a couple months I don't know
time is flying lately for me uh so
anyway this is the one that we want so
I'm going to go ahead and copy that path
and I'm going to paste it in here so
that's the model name that I want to use
then I also am going to say OS dot uh
yeah and virun
and in this case I don't want that what
I want to do is Cuda thank you visible
devices so this is where you can set the
index of your GPU to be visible for this
script so for example if you had
multiple gpus uh I think in my case Zero
is going to be
I'm actually not even sure I think it's
probably a 30 90 but I I can't even
remember now anyways
uh that should be fine
um actually I might change that I'm
gonna go to two because two is the at
least for me uh we'll have plenty of
memory on that one so okay so anyways if
you need to do that do that if you are
just running it on CPU and RAM that's
totally fine then no worries so uh the
then I guess sure that we can take that
line uh tokenizer equals Auto tokenizer
from pre-train so we're loading in the
tokenizer and then we also need to load
in the model
uh from pre-trained uh model uh and then
okay so before so we'll take that line
and I'm actually going to remove the dot
Cuda and the reason why is I'll actually
I want to run this at a half Precision
another reason you might want to run at
half Precision is Just For Speed so it's
going to be considerably faster at half
Precision so
um you do either one but if you
definitely are running it purely because
you can't fit it uh but you can fit it
in like CPU and RAM but you can't fit it
on your GPU the first thing you're going
to really need to do or want to do is
going to be model equals model and then
first cut it in half or run it a half
precision and then send it to your GPU
so that's what we're going to do next
we're going to specify some input so
this will be our input string and we're
going to say what uh color is the sky
for example that might be some of your
inputs now one thing to keep in mind is
and we'll get to it soon where it is my
browser this model has the following
special tokens it has prompter assistant
and then end of text and that is used
end of text happens to be at every end
of turn so to speak so
um I guess it's sort of a valid use case
I've never seen that token used that way
so if you're not if you're used to
always just like truly the end of the
sequence generation being end of text uh
take that into account so for example
you'll have prompter what does it mean
blah blah but then at the end of that
prompt you'll have end of text and then
you'll have the actual kind of like
coaxing and the prompting of hey now
return the assistance response you'll
have you'll have a tag you'll have
something coming after end of text so
keep that in mind
um anyways so we could pass a string
like this and it should probably
actually still work but keep in mind
that you're actually going to probably
be wanting to use these these uh tokens
now we'll use more we'll use those
shortly but I just want to show a really
quick basic example of working with this
model uh and then we're going to
continue building on top of that so no
worries we will get there so once you
have some input string we are going to
do input IDs that is going to be
correct
um yep that's everything we want to do
thank you copilot so input IDs we encode
with the tokenizer we pass the input we
do want to return Pi torch tensors and
then we're going to send that to the GPU
we send that to the GPU because that is
where our model is if you're not running
your model on the GPU don't send your
tokens to the GPU so once we've done
that we are ready to actually
generate now again if you're if you were
just running this in CPU and RAM you
probably actually could get away with
what it's suggesting me to do just do a
quick model generate but if you're
running on the GPU what you're going to
want to say is with
torch.cuda.amp that stands for automatic
mixed Precision we are going to Auto
cast and auto cast is automatically
casting the data type for things so like
flute 1632 all that kind of stuff it's
just going to automatically do that for
us
um the output now
um that's close to what I want but uh
I think I'll take that and I'm just
going to remove
this max length
um I think 100 is a bit short I think
eventually you probably should set your
max length to the true max length
um but which is 2048 for this model if
you didn't know
um which is actually a pretty
substantial context size
um usually it's like 10 24 and so 2048
it's really nice I wish we had like an
8K context model and I'm looking very
much forward to open source models with
gigantic contexts so if you're someone
working in that space or you're aware of
some project working in that space let
me know so anyways I'm going to set max
length to 256. do sample this is whether
or not you want to do random or greedy
sampling so in this case we'll allow for
random sampling it'll give us a more
variety in our responses but you could
also set that to false if you want uh
then the only thing uh well we're gonna
add a couple more things so first of all
we're going to add early underscore or
stopping and I'm going to say that is
equal to true and then we are going to
say the end of string token ID is equal
to model and you can just dynamically
grab this for each model so
model.config.eos
token underscore ID is what we're
looking for let me make sure that it
actually did what I wanted it to yes it
did and then it also finished
it really wants me to throw in those
other uh parameters a number of return
sequences and we already
do that or no
oh maybe I already had that or something
I don't know anyways maybe I'm confusing
myself
um and uh number of return sequences
that's fine let me go ahead and close
this off and I think we're good
that's a little messy there I started
running out of space as I was recording
so I like interrupted my uh thought
process here uh I'm trying to think if
there's anything else I haven't like
mentioned here so uh early stopping
equals true just means if we hit a stop
token uh it will stop generating it's
kind of save us processing time because
otherwise in the logic we're going to
trim off any extra anyways so there's
multiple ways that we can handle for
that so in our case we're trying to make
this into a chat model so uh let me pull
it back up the example that it had
um yeah so in this case uh you know this
might be your input to the model right
you've got prompter what does it mean
what's the history blah blah blah uh and
then you hit compute let's oh is it
gonna error but tokens okay well I don't
know anyways you'll see example in a
minute anyways but it's just going to
continue generating a response that's
all these generative models do they just
have some input context and then they
just generate a they just continue
generating in this case it's going to
generate an assistant-like response
because you've prompted it that hey
we've got prompter now we've got we're
asking for an assistant please and it's
just going to continue generating but
the thing is after it's done generating
an assistance response it's going to
probably almost certainly generate a
prompter token and then generate what it
thinks might be a good next prompt you
know so so in general if you're trying
to make it into an actual chat bot what
you're going to want to do is like stop
the response at the end of the
assistance response so that's what we're
doing with this kind of like early
stopping once we get to end of text or
end of sentence or whatever you see EOS
is usually end of string I guess uh and
in our case we're calling it end of text
or something but anyways we will do that
we'll just stop there and it saves a lot
of processing
and then we're just going to return one
sequence we don't want to have a you
know a list of of them to choose from so
okay so I think that's uh all we need
once we have
our output we will come down here and
what we're going to do now is uh output
equals output dot CP U so we're going to
send the output because right now it's
on the GPU we're going to send it to the
CPU and then finally we are going to
decode it so we're going to say output
underscore text equals tokenizer and Dot
decode output we're going to grab the
zero with we only returned one element
anyways but we're just going to grab it
that specific one and then skip special
tokens if you are using copilot this is
going to annoy you with these models in
our case I want that set to false and
what that's going to do is it's going to
take those special tokens of assistant
and prompter and end of sentence or end
of text rather and it will just ignore
them it won't show them in the output
which is convenient in some scenarios I
suppose but in our case we actually want
those because we want to handle for them
in our logic
so we have output text and then now what
we're going to do is print that output
text and finally we are ready to run our
very first example all right so I will
open this up I always forget on this
machine I think python3 yeah okay uh
python three what was it basic oasst so
on first running this might actually
take a considerable amount of time
because you might have to actually
download the model first and then you'll
be able to run it
um so it could take yeah I don't know 10
15 minutes otherwise it should take
about a minute or so to load it in so I
can just open up a few things here
and we can watch it load in together so
I don't know what my starting memory was
but you should see about 48 gigs of
memory load in initially because we
won't run it at half until we can cut it
load it fully and then cut it in half
essentially
um so we're just going to kind of wait
on that I guess
so I'm guessing we're at least getting
close it looks like it's chopping that
model it just chopped the model in half
and then we can see it loading up the
model onto the RTX 8000 here
uh looks like it's already actually
processing at the moment for a response
I assume possibly looks like it's still
loading up uh the response time on a GPU
should be about a second or so so I
guess we're just still waiting I'm gonna
move each top out of the way now
okay so
um
what color is the sky uh so in this case
it actually didn't give us a
assistant-like response it actually
looks like it tried to produce a
multiple choice exam of sorts or
something and the reason for this is we
didn't use the tag so it was not clear
to the model I think that you know it
was supposed to answer that question so
for example
um I you don't I guess I could break it
I'll just I'll just keep cutting out the
loading time so for example uh this it
was just it's just going to continue
that generation because that's all
generative models do they just continue
some sort of sequence so it's no
surprise it didn't answer that question
so to get it to answer that question if
I can ever open backup thank you
I probably look really weird like trying
to open up various things anyways uh so
what we're going to do now is we're
going to use the tags that we're
supposed to use so if we use prompter
and then end of text and then assistant
like that and we save that
and then we re-run that now we got to
load that all the way back up into
memory again cut it in half put it onto
the GPU and this is why the next step
that we're going to do is actually build
our our own API now there are a couple
things that people might say is like oh
well you could use a Jupiter notebook or
something like that and you can so you
could load it in your notebook and then
do all your like r d and stuff but
chances are you're probably trying if
you're using models like this you're
probably trying to use them and access
them on things like Raspberry Pi's or
other machines entirely you're not
always going to want to be in a notebook
environment so instead I think the best
way to like do r d with these models is
to just host them locally as an API
service just to yourself so so
um that's what I've been doing with
these models myself and so I decided to
finally just go ahead and share with you
guys uh the process I go through to do
that
and in fact because this is I don't
I can't remember if I'm actually on my
GPU for recording or not uh but I think
we'll be fine I think while we wait for
the response on here we actually could
begin building the API so let me
move that
and oops not a folder
uh open in terminal and let's call this
touch open Assistant API dot pi
and I'll just close that and we will
open
and visual code
I'm trying to decide where I want to put
this
I just want to make it smaller and put
it on a different there we go I'll pull
I'll try to remember to pull that up
when it's done
um okay so now what we want to do is
build our oh it's actually done okay
coming back
so in this case you can see okay so this
was our input prompt and then we just we
stopped at assistant and then as you can
see it just responds blue and then end
of text and again it stopped there
because we told it hey stop at those
inputs because at this point you would
conceivably show that and then you would
just be waiting for another input from a
user to ask another question or a
follow-up question and so on So Okay
cool so moving that aside
now we're going to do is build our
little API so from flask we're going to
import capital F flask request and
jsonify
uh the next thing we're going to do
cores
it's cores
I don't know what that is but uh
that's curious I'm always curious
whenever it suggests things I've never
heard of
um comment below if you know what Coors
is anyways uh from trance formers we're
going to import those two things we're
going to import torch and it's just
knows we're going to import OS it knows
we're going to Define our app for flask
app if if this then sets my GPU I'm
going to lose my mind I didn't but it's
okay uh we're going to say OS Dot and
viron
you'll at least get that part right
thank you sir we do want that model name
that's good and in fact uh tokenizer
good model yes
model half Cuda cool we'll take it very
good um I'm just gonna do that because
you guys can just copy and paste that if
you want so now what we want to do to
make an app an API with flask it's
actually unbelievably simple uh we're
going to Define our root app Root
um
I personally had used generate so I'm
going to keep it as generate just to
keep everything the same as it always
has been for me and so that is our app
Root then we're going to Define
generate and in fact let me
um
make that a little bigger we'll Define
generate and then we're going to say
content equals
request dot Json
and then we are going to say the input
to this model is going to be content
um
man I always I remember asking why
if there's any difference here but
anyways contacts.get and we're going to
get text
and the default will be just an empty
string if someone does a post request
with nothing
then input IDs tokenizer and code input
return tensors DSHS throw it to Cuda
only if you're using GPU so if you're
using CPU and RAM don't do that dot Cuda
part
um very good and now actually I'm not
going to retype this uh same line I'm
going to copy and paste Boop copy
and then I'm going to come down here
paste fix our tab issue
so again uh with the automatic mix
Precision Auto casting we are going to
generate we're going to allow a max
length and in our case since this is
going to be API we're going to actually
set that to 2048 we'll talk about a
little bit more about that in a moment
um but everything else looks good
so then what we'll do is we will say uh
whoops
decoded
equals and actually we probably
that actually gets Auto sent
um in this in that case it would
actually automatically go to your CPU
after this context
and like as soon as you tried to do the
decode and then return it I think
I think that would go
probably automatic back to the CPU so
anyways continue on decoded and then
what we're going to do is return that's
kind of like
if there's ever problems with python
that's these are like the common
problems like sometimes it's like too
simple and
like I this might not actually be
required in all cases you know
anyways
um we can test that later if I remember
to
uh anyway so then so basically if you
access this URL on our little API
and you post a Json with a key of text
and the value is that text you will get
your
um
uh that will be your like input to the
model and then it's going to generate a
continuation of that sequence uh let me
make sure it didn't uh
uh where's that uh skip specialty at
false cool
um
it will it will then decode that and
then it's going to return again text and
that decoded output so
um cool so once you have that we are
going to just need to run it so if name
equals main yes app dot run and in our
case host will be zero zero zero
and then Port 5000 is fine
so I'll go ahead and save that and now
what I'm going to do is come back over
to this window that I've been using and
let's go ahead and Python 3 open
Assistant API dot pi
so in my case
um let me think here I think uh I'm
going to just let me just make this a
little smaller move it
so now effectively we have an API
running on this machine I'm going to
access it from this machine but in
theory you could access this from any
machine in network and then you could
even host it publicly if you wanted and
access it from anywhere in the world so
for example you could get a VPS or
something like that and host it for
yourself if you don't have enough local
power but for me I'm just going to host
it locally so now we're going to make a
yet another file and this one I'm going
to call
rename I'm gonna call it chat
openassistant.pi and then now how whoops
I meant to say API
and now what we're going to do is write
some logic around the idea of uh
conversing essentially with our API so
we're going to do import
requests in oops import Json yes and
we're going to import colorama to just
kind of give us a little bit of
color so now
that's another one I actually don't know
if we actually have to initialize
colorama
uh anyway continuing on uh server IP we
will set and in my case that's a local
IP of 10 not 0 0 18.
uh sever IP server IPs server IP oh this
is getting tough okay so anyway let me
pull up this so it looks like at least
so far everything worked but if
something's not going to work uh it's
going to first require a query so we'll
get there if it doesn't work out of the
box so first we set server IP then we're
going to set the URL to access our
server and that is
I've always wondered if uh
uh copilot can access the other files in
the directory at least and and if not
it's if it's not in that directory how
does it anyways that's good enough for
me that's exactly what we were hoping to
do and there's no way I would know this
without unless it was because I did the
copy and paste that's totally possible
anyways user token is equal to uh we'll
take we'll just uh we'll fill that in in
a moment uh and in fact uh at least in
my previous work I didn't have that
underscore so I won't do that end token
hello
and token and in this case I'll just
leave it empty and then assistant
token equals empty okay
um so to get that we will
grab this so user token is prompter
end of text token
is that and then finally assistant token
is that okay so now we've got our
various constants set up we're going to
Define uh prompt prompt we'll take an
input then we're going to specify the
actual data and in this case
um
uh we could build it here but I actually
am just going to build it uh logically
below so we're going to say text and
then this by this point the input will
have already been built uh uh and then
we're going to specify headers uh in
this case we probably don't really need
headers to be honest
it's okay we'll just take the re uh
basic headers now we're going to say
response equals and then request.post uh
URL yes uh Json dump the data and then
headers yes so so we're just going to
make a post request to our API and we
will get that response which will
hopefully be a Json object and then if
um in this case we actually can
let's see um what was the API
so in our case yeah this
um I want to change this I'm going to
call this generated underscore text like
that
so oh I can't change that can I I guess
we'd have to wait for it to I'm going to
do that uh
I don't really want to wait for that but
anyways I gotta so if you make that
change with me you need to restart your
API otherwise that's not going to work
out so I wanted to differentiate between
text and then generated text probably
should call that input text but uh it's
okay coming back down here
um
so we're gonna get that response and
then uh here
we will return response.json and in this
case it will be generated underscore
text that's what we're looking for
we could theoretically hit an error on
that and I'm going to pretend that
that's not possible at the moment
so in this and then now what we're going
to do is
um I don't need a main function actually
so we're going to say history and right
now history is going to be empty and
then what we're going to say is while
true thank you sir
um no way that it could know possibly
what I wanted oh my gosh
this is probably good enough
um I'm gonna make it match the code that
I've already written however because I'm
gonna I'm gonna upload this probably
just to like GitHub or something like
that so I want it to be identical
that's kind of funny though
um so then so we will get the user from
the input uh
if we ever get the input from the user
oh my goodness okay uh context is now
going to equal whatever the history was
plus the user token plus the input plus
the end token plus the assistant token
correct so the current context is going
to equal that then what we want to do is
probably yes we will prompt based on
that context then we're going to say we
do want to print there
um
but in this case we actually we don't
want
um
because the output actually is going to
contain
everything including the prompt so we're
going to have to fix that so now we're
going to do is
so then now history is going to equal
the full output so we're just going to
redefine what history is and then what
we want to do is print colorama
um
yeah it's so close to what I really
wanted but not quite so really what we
want here is like uh just latest
assistant output and that is going to be
equal to Output dot a split uh assistant
token yeah we want the very last element
and then we actually want to skip that
end token too so split end token
uh is copilot just too good I mean man
okay
um now we're good so let's go ahead and
save that it looks like my API is back
up and running and now
uh we will open in terminal python3
please work
work chat
oh we should have had a space there hey
there
hey there
um how do you what can I do for you
today so interestingly enough uh we did
not get
split by assistant
that's what we did right
hold on
I thought that's what we did
um coming down here
oh we didn't okay that's we built this
but then we didn't do anything with it
cool okay save that and then let's go
ahead and fix with the space there and
then we will try again okay
hi there
which root
hi there it is a pleasure to meet you
how can I help you today I don't know
what
can you do
it's a lot apparently
so as an artificial intelligence
language model I can read and reply to
emails and messages I would not let open
Assistant do that for you generate text
on various topics yeah probably perform
online tasks such as web searches uh
nope can't do that
um
okay uh can you show me some basic mat
plot lib code
apparently this is a lot of matplotlib
code
okay so you got some basic matplotlib
and then uh
that's uh oh it did make it uh can you
show me a line graph instead
so you get the idea uh it's already a
pretty decent chat app just with those
those things done and then now every
time we want to just make any
modification or build another piece of
software that interacts with this
specific model we can do that now we
only have one slight problem the problem
is the if the if this conversation goes
on long enough
what's going to happen is we're going to
have a context window context that is
just too big so if you the maximum size
that this model can take is 2048 tokens
now 2048 tokens is a lot of tokens but
if you just keep going on this context
or in this chat you are going to hit it
so what we can do to kind of handle for
that and I think probably round off this
specific video it's getting quite long
is to add a little bit of a cushion
basically to always allow for because
basically the context so the history has
to be less than 2048 but you also need
to account for well how long might the
model's response be so in general like
128 is probably comfy 256 is like very
comfy and then 512 would be like
extremely comfortable like it would be a
surprise if the model generated 512
tokens of a response but I suppose it's
plausible
but also it's unlikely that you're going
to need a history much bigger than 2048
anyways so uh so what I'm going to do
now is we'll break that
I'm going to start that fresh anyways
I'm also going to break the API and that
is where we're going to make this change
you could make this change at the
assistant level and it might make sense
to to make this change at that low or at
the chat level rather and it might make
sense to do it at that level but
there's a bunch of different ways that
you can handle for something like this
so another option is as the context
approaches
um you know let's say 1500 tokens you
might instead use that language model
that you're using right now to actually
summarize the history try to condense it
down and then now that becomes the new
one and then you just keep doing that
just keep summarizing down the context
and I think you could probably do that
with some success depending on what uh
you know what kind of
application you're actually building
here with this chat model but anyways
what we're going to do is something a
little more basic and we're going to do
it at the API level and all we're going
to do is just trim the
um the context if it's too big so first
what we're going to do is we'll just
come up to our
um
constants here and we're going to say
Max
context length and this will be
dependent on the actual model the the
answer is 2048 but I kind of want this
API to be usable for different models so
in my case I'm going to say model dot
config.max position embeddings
um
oh
I'm actually not sure why it's minus two
is that for the special tokens probably
I don't know why would it why would it
default to that but anyway this this
this will be 2048 I'm not sure why it
says minus two it's got to be for like
end of is like special token I don't
know someone comment again below if I
miss if I'm wrong on that but anyways uh
let's just go ahead and make a print
really quick Max context link cool I
just want to see what it is make sure we
got that right and then we're going to
say room for response so how much of a
cushion do we want to leave uh for a
response and in my case I'm going to say
512.
so now that we have those values the
next thing that we want to do is we're
going to come down
um
oh my gosh we're in the chat
okay cut that nice coming over to API
now coming back up here
coming over here
pacing that there uh now what we want to
do is we're going to come to basically
here at the encoding process and this is
partly why I wanted to just put it in
here because this is already gonna have
the tokenizer loaded you could take a
guess at how many tokens a string is
based on how many characters that string
is
um but in general tokens are going to be
multiple characters so if you just want
to be perfect this is the way to do it
probably but we could also you could
load the tokenizer the tokenizer is like
very lightweight to load and use but
anyways coming over here input IDs
tokenizer in code so once we have that
what we're going to want to say is we'll
say print and then we're going to say
the context length is currently uh
hello give me that back
uh input ids.shape one yes that's
correct tokens that's fine we can leave
that so again at it's going to actually
be at that like first index so keep that
in mind for the next few lines that
we're going to write
um
so this tells us where we are and then
if we needed to trim it what we're going
to say is just add a bit of logic and
we're just going to say if input
ids.shape at the first is greater than
Max context length minus room for
response cool
and I'm actually going to take the
suggestion here because that's fine and
the only thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to add some parentheses here this
shouldn't be required but it just always
makes me nervous okay so context length
is too long truncating yes and in this
case we are just simply trimming at the
at the first element here and we're just
going to say we want everything from the
negative context length plus how
whatever room for response we want to
make and then uh everything you know
from that point forward
so now minus
and once again I'm just going to do this
and that should allow for us to just
infinitely converse with this
um
oh shoot actually
I think we could probably do that on the
GPU but I'm not positive so I'm going to
cut the Cuda part and then we're going
to send it here to the GPU
okay so I'm going to save that I'm going
to restart the API get that running
put that back up here
UPS
um model is not defined yet uh uh let's
just move that
cutting that to here
so it just I got an error that said the
model is not defined uh and we were just
trying to access model before we had
actually defined it so saving that again
and
restarting the API
okay it looks like our server is up so
let me make a window bigger here
and
python
python3 chat
hey how's it going
yo just getting through another day how
about you
big chillin
good you
as
I knew we would finally we would
eventually get there as this
conversation became more uh informal
um with no awareness of my activities
I'm able to answer that question good
luck with your day
um okay anyway uh that's good enough for
now as you can see uh you know it's a
pretty good model uh there's a little
bit of this as an AI language models
nonsense
um the good news is if you want it to do
things that normally you'd get this type
of response from say chat GPT
you can use prompting to get around this
and kind of hack your way into these
sort of behavior that you're after
um so I definitely suggest that you play
around with this model it's a pretty
powerful model for being only 12 billion
parameters and I like I said to at the
beginning it's constantly under
development and there's there's just
there's so many open source models
coming out right now I do like what open
Assistant has been doing especially open
sourcing like their data set the
training of that like everything is open
source so I really like what they're
doing there
um so definitely keep an eye out for
what they're up to and all that and some
of the models that they're coming out
with they do have some of the other like
llama based models I'm opting to like
not touch the Llama models purely
because the the license just doesn't
seem to make much sense to me for use
also they those models like weren't even
supposed to be out so uh it's a little
unclear like what can you really do
truly do you can play with those models
but what can you actually
do with those models and how can you use
those models is kind of unclear and with
that in mind it doesn't seem to me like
a good idea to spend a whole bunch of
time getting good at working with those
models or building anything off of them
so uh anyways uh I think that's all for
now if you've got questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you guys
in another video